if this is a crime story it turns out in
the end that everybody did it hi I'm
Michael Moynihan of Reason TV and today
we are with Johan Norberg the author of
financial Fiasco how America's
infatuation with homeownership and easy
money created the economic crisis thanks
for being with us Yann thank you so this
is a general overview of what caused the
financial crisis give us a give us a
brief description of what you're arguing
in this book well it's an attempt to
really have this broad perspective on
different factors including both
political factors and economic financial
factors and what I'm saying is that it's
a combination of cheap money the fact
that the Fed sink restrains decisions in
the early 21st century made so much
liquidity and easy money available so it
had to go somewhere and it ended up in
real estate and partly because of a
political will to increase homeownership
it led to an enormous real-estate bubble
and then we had different financial
regulations the way we regulate credit
rating agencies capital requirements and
other things built up a whole system of
securities of bonds that were based on
these real estate values and then put in
a fairly untranslatable transparent
shadow banking sector and we're given
great ratings and they became huge
bestsellers around the world and then
all it took was a reduction in home
values and then everything came tumbling
down one of the myths that seems to have
arisen in the in in the fallout here is
that the bush administration was was you
know slashing regulations left and right
you said it's the opposite of that is
true yeah actually President Clinton
reduced regulation on financial markets
a little bit and the Bush administration
definitely increased it a lot we got 210
new pages of regulation every day under
the Bush presidency and that's a faster
pace than ever in America's history we
saw that in when it comes to these
regulations generally on financial
markets what you're allowed to do but
also when it comes to the
kind of political goals that they gave
and people on the market for example the
government-sponsored enterprises like
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac who had this
whole mission to make sure that more
mortgages went to people who could not
afford a mortgage on on the free market
and Bush increased that a lot and
increased the proportion of loans that
were supposed to go to people with low
income from 50% to 56% the number of
loans that were supposed to go to people
with a very low income increased from 20
to 28 percent and very low income means
you will not afford this house in the
future you previously mentioned the
federal reserve for a lot of people this
is a difficult concept to understand
myself included so you you basically
have the Federal Reserve pumping up this
bubble explain to us how this happened
why this happened this happened in a
situation that was very similar to where
we are today people are afraid of a an
economic crisis a bubble has just been
deflated at that time it was the dot-com
come bubble and we have been 9/11
terrorist terrorist attacks in 2001 and
then everybody said well what they're
saying today feds gotta save us somehow
they gotta make sure that there's a lot
of easy money in the economy so what
they did is that they lowered interest
rates dramatically made it possible for
people to borrow at a much cheaper costs
and lowering the interest rate from 6.75
to 1.75 percent in one year and
continued to reduce the interest rate
until it was down to one percent and
this basically means especially if
you've got a little implement inflation
that it's almost a negative interest
rate you basically make money by
borrowing from others it becomes
expensive to hold capital you won't get
any return yourself so instead you need
more leverage borrowing from others this
affected financial markets a lot because
then you try to find riskier asset
classes and you try to borrow more to
invest in them to get a return but it
also affects households because you can
suddenly see that oh my mortgage is much
less expensive if I get an adjustable
rate means that it feels like I'm
getting a house for free as someone put
it when they you tell you tell a story
in the book of somebody in Atlanta
correct who says I feel like I'm getting
a house for free and actually ends up
getting a third property on an
interest-only mortgage this as as you
point out was was driven not only to
save mark ISM after after the talk combo
but there's political interference here
tell us a little about how politics
played in this obsession with home
ownership well well it's an American
legend a myth almost the American dream
of having a home of your own and it's a
good one and as a Swede I really admire
that part of the American Dream but the
whole idea from the beginning was that
you are working hard to to earn this to
make sure that you earn your own home
but this suddenly changed with a
political idea of making sure that
people get a home first and then we'll
try to get well people can even
refinance by getting a second mortgage
because the price of the houses has
increased a lot but we've got them this
battery of policies that were aimed at
making sure that more people enter the
housing market we've got deductions of
the the interest rates we've got
government insurances to make sure that
they'll pay if you cannot pay we've got
some pressure on private lenders to make
sure that they lend more to people with
the low income but specifically we've
got the government's been sitting
sponsored enterprises Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac the whole point of which was
to make sure that more people enter the
market more people got a mortgage and
these were not small corporations they
were some of the world's largest you in
your book say this isn't primarily a
bipartisan thing this is something that
that everyone is trying to benefit from
politically is that to give us an idea
of like you know who is fundamentally
responsible is it a both party thing is
that actually right yeah if this is a
crime story it turns out in the end that
everybody did it everybody had an
interest in inflating this bubble
because it it was really it was like
apple pie everybody loved this from left
to right it's home ownership its
property rights something for the right
to make sure that people own something
for themselves and they become become
citizens and in that regard for the left
it was to oppose discrimination to make
sure that even the poorest of the poor
could own a house of their own and they
were involved all of them and now
they're trying to blame one another now
they're looking at just the parts of
them the pieces of the puzzle where the
other
site made mistakes and then they tried
to pretend that they did not do this
let's take this out of it further so we
have an American housing bubble we have
a Fed that is that is creating
incredibly cheap money how is this
spreading out globally you have a
chapter in the book or you have a
section in the book where you talk about
the collapse for instance of Iceland
which is a colossal collapse and this is
rocking markets across across the globe
how is that happening yeah well you can
say as someone who was involved in this
and American banks and lenders were they
did bad things and it's strange that
they really could create all these
securities based on these very risky
mortgages but even stranger is the fact
that others bought this and took on
these risks and that was the part that
really made this global the fact that
banks and governments all around the
world they bought into and they wanted a
piece of the action so they bought
mortgage-backed securities and that
means that everybody was so incredibly
exposed to this bubble when it began to
deflate the final chapter in your book
is called tomorrow capitalism with the
question mark what is what does this
mean for for capitalism for free markets
for less a fair economics is the
foundations are being shaken right now
and we have people that are nominally
right-of-center saying hey this is the
markets fault
are we seeing like an enormous crisis in
capitalism and tell us a little bit
about the last chapter in the book well
yeah yeah we are witnessing a a huge
crisis of capitalism and especially when
it comes to our our vision of what
capitalism is about because we do know
that people on the market have made
colossal mistakes banks and investment
banks have made bizarre mistakes that
they should have been able to foresee so
obviously it's easy to blame them for
what happened and I certainly I'm one of
those who who blame them
so therefore we see a backlash all over
the world the problem is that people
don't really realize that the
regulator's the central banks and the
politicians they were inflating the
bubble just as eagerly they only had a
bigger pump so they could do it even
more dramatically and and that's
something that we're missing now when
people think that the response is to
bail out all the misguided investments
to regulate financial markets even more
and and that's building up problems for
the future one of the biggest problems I
think is that we're now giving all the
actors on the financial markets an idea
that now they definitely got a
government guarantee in the future
because the government will always step
in and bail them out if there's a
mistake if there's a problem somewhere
and then we'll see worse risks Johan
Norberg author of a financial Fiasco
which is at now and can be purchased
online at amazon.com and fine bookstores
everywhere thanks for joining us thank
you for reason TV I'm Michael Moynihan